actually had a wrestle with a dude with
a gun not long ago what yeah
so we we were having for a discovery
again yeah
and they didn't pay me
me and my girl were having a picnic down
at the lagoon at um playa del rey yeah
and so we're just in there we'd had two
bottles of maui it was kind of like a
special date day
uh smashed two bottles of moe and all of
a sudden the the homeless guys from the
toilet block
came running over there's like four of
them they're like get behind the rock
this guy with the gun
so i put everyone behind the rock and
obviously i head towards the road where
the guy with the gun is for some strange
reason
there there's couple did you have a gun
i had nothing no nothing and so there's
a guy on the phone calling the police
and there's a couple talking about and
they're pointing down the roads like
what's going on so there's this guy down
the end of the street in a white prius
he's been he was waving a gun around
he's got out of the car and i'm watching
him and then he gets back in the car and
so i asked them
where does this road go because there's
one way and they say it goes up around
the block and comes out the other side
on the other side of these buildings
so i say how can we get up there and
they say yeah you just cut through these
buildings here so i'm like you on the
phone you come with me you guys you stay
here
cut through the building there's people
on the streets having balcony uh having
balcony parties
and so i yell at him and i say hey guys
there's a there's a dude with a gun
coming down the street everyone should
go inside so they all stay on their
balconies
yeah as you can see everyone listen
no not now no one they it's so
get your phones out exactly that's the
guy from discovery
we're gonna see a shooter give me a shot
man this is great
so the guy on the phone and say stay
behind the cars and he's the dude in the
car has come up around the corner his
white prius he's just sitting at the end
of the street doing nothing
so i'm watching him through the window
waiting to see if he moves and he starts
coming down the street so i time it so
i'm not in front of the car but i'm in
an awkward enough position that he has
to stop if he doesn't want to hit me
and he stops and i start going overtly
friendly yelling like i'm at a party i'm
a little drunk like hey what's going on
man
and i walk around the back of the car
checking the windows to make sure no one
else is in there there's no other guns
and i come up on his window
and i just be friend what's going on
what are you doing i glanced down and
he's sitting
in his seat with his hand on a pistol
like that and so
i asked him a question he starts to
answer i jab down for the gun and i grab
his hand and his gun in the same
grip and he panics he yells he hits the
accelerator
and my arm gets hit by the edge of the
window and pulls it off the gun
and he just bolts and that's the end of
the story
let me ask you why is that your instinct
australian captain america i know
i'm like he's down there okay i'm gonna
head this way here's what's here's
what's funny by the way when you're
walking down the street
when i first met you you had the
three-piece suit and you had the you
looked like a bond villain
because he had he had the perfect yeah
when he's walking down the street
looking like captain america you know
people are like
day saved i love that he's like you
get inside you over here and everyone's
like
rocks a good friend of mine and he keeps
telling me he's going to put me in his
movies as a bad guy so i'm just waiting
for him
to give me a flamethrower or something
yes yeah
wolverine you call the cops and then
they picked up the guy on the phone
called the cops and they pulled i went
back down again
what the [ __ ] was he doing just what's
your game plan like what
you're hoping just to take the gun and
then what yeah and just if i can detain
him
wait for the police then do that if not
at least drive him away because he's
this is a family neighborhood it's quiet
that's a great day
yeah it's beautiful and so you can't
just go driving around a neighborhood
flashing a gun that's [ __ ] not on
your watch
not after i've had two battles of maui
would you say yeah
god i wish you lived in my neighborhood
if there was any problems i'm like i'm
calling paul
yeah i'm going to call paul he'll come
over and my friends think i'm
stupid yeah so i just went back down and
continued the
and was that and that was when you your
first date with your girl she's probably
like what the [ __ ]
was she like did paul just leave me with
these four homeless guys yeah yeah yeah
yeah he just ran here hey fellas watch
it
yeah yeah eat as much of the food you
need to yeah yeah
i'm glad to know the story two bottles
in you're like
let's go [ __ ] this guy with a gun up
yeah that's probably more so than if i
didn't have it
yeah i was booted it was like months
into corona i was so
bored i needed some excitement some
action yeah it'd be how terror had been
if you went to go and just like
shot you in the in your arms and your
girls like what the [ __ ]
are you doing dude i really didn't think
i'm not bad at all pretty gangster dude
too bad you're not a cop when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son